we're going to take a look at photos
real memory in Texas a dam at panera
lake has been fractured after the state
received 11 inches of rain earlier this
week officials fear the dam will break
and flood highway 287 with over 15 feet
of water residents evacuated area
traffic is been herded until the issue
is fixed these pictures are
extraordinary watch this all day
yesterday I think I saw one foot of rain
in five minutes yeah i think was one
statistic we got a lot of mail people
say why aren't you covering this more ya
got listeners and you say what isn't
that is it as an economic issue okay
number two in spain scientists
discovered what they believe is the
world's oldest this is murderer
assistant producer that's right you can
you can see the hole right there in the
skull the skull is four hundred and
thirty thousand years old to depression
fractures above the lest I left I of
course Tom as you can see immediately
that is blunt-force trauma I would say
so but a hockey stick with a hockey
stick what was a hockey stick lacrosse
stick one of the two number one I love
this picture Oxon Hill Maryland Audrey
frisch makes a face after having to
spell the world aab novel ate an omelet
no no I cannot and i'm reading the
teleplay smell exact for me thank you
another number late I'm knob you late
that's kind of how Tom feels after that
word is requested finals for the 88th
annual Scripps National Spelling Bee
will be tonight 49 kids left that's the
semi-finals where this morning the
winner gets a five-thousand-dollar price
i won my teacher elementary school
spelling bee but I name but I did not
advance